hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna try to make the search inputs in
the app bar and the side drawer work
there so the idea is a user would type
into that input and then hit enter or
click on the little search icon and then
the user would go then be taken to the
search page and a search would
automatically occur okay so I have a few
ideas for how this could work we're
gonna try them out and we can talk about
it if you'll have any ideas please feel
free to mention it in the live chat for
those of you who are new to the show you
are watching me work on an actual
project for my job I'm a full time
front-end developer employed by a small
University so we're working on the the
new main website for the university so
this is not rehearsed it's not exactly a
tutorial it's just me going through what
I'm doing but I do my best to explain
things and feel free to ask any
questions
if you need me to explain things in more
depth I will make mistakes and that's
kind of the point
y'all can see how many mistakes I make
and how I work through the mistakes I
break things up by Pomodoro sessions so
Pomodoro session is usually the 25
minute period followed by a five-minute
break and so for 25 minutes will code
and I'll have minimal interaction with
the live chat and then for 5 minutes
I'll go back to the chat answer any
questions and read all the comments that
you have we'll probably go back and
forth and do two Pomodoro sessions and
then at the end of the second session I
will go through all the questions in the
chat and answer you know any anything
that that you all have asked to the best
of my ability so the stream will
probably last somewhere between an hour
an hour and a half that's usually the
the time
that we have okay look I got all the
intro stuff out of the way of doing my
best to try to remember to do that for
for all the new new people so enough
looking at my face let me switch over to
the code alright here we are
mmm let's start with the UI first so
y'all can see how this this actually
looks and I'll start up an end grog
server I'm gonna paste a link here into
the live chat if you go to this URL you
will be able to see the site I'm working
on and it will update live as I am
working on it here alright so that link
is is now in the chat and it looks like
you're clicking on it
awesome so let me that's the dev side I
guess I don't have a look oh is that it
localhost okay alright so we have two
search boxes we have this one up top and
we have this one in the side nav so
those are what we're going to be working
on and then we have a search page that
we're going to navigate to so justjust
you get an idea of where things are at
and these are available from any page on
the website so there they're always
gonna have this unless you're on mobile
then we get rid of this on the on the
app bar but it's always there in that
side drawer and let me start my timer
because we're gonna get into the code
now
so I have the component for search j/s
here and if you are interested in
looking at the code there's a link to
the github repo in the description so
this is quite a large component and
could probably use some refactoring but
for now we're gonna we're to leave it
like this
what we we need to do in this component
is create some way to trigger the search
okay when we navigate to that so we need
to make sure that we can get the value
from the the input and then use that to
search now over here I have the side
drawer component so on the right and
with this component
we've already I've already done a little
bit with it okay so just some basics
stuff I've put in let's see an on click
Handler and it goes to the handle search
function so let's go up to see the
handle search function and see what
we're doing
okay so it handles search all we're
doing is saying if a user has actually
entered in something into that search
box then we're going to do a router dot
push now this uses the next j/s built-in
router so if you want to learn more
about that you can go to the
documentation for next j/s it's on
github they have a website so I'm if you
type in next Jas github it'll probably
be the first result that comes up and it
has a lot more about how their router
works but in this case we're giving it a
path name and then we are using that
search term so whatever the user typed
into that input get saved in-state so
we're just accessing that that state for
the search input and we're passing that
along as a query string so let me show
you how this this looks when we do this
it's going to be hard to see because the
you know the app the address bar is is a
little small but we could type in
something basic like the and if I hit
actually I didn't enable the Enter key
yet I just have the click working so if
i click
maybe it's not working let's try that
again there we are okay so when I
clicked it took me up here and just in
case you can't read it I'll read this
out so we now have we're on the search
page so it's slash search and then
question mark search equals the there's
a week we have in the URL the search
term so I figured that will probably be
the main way that we can we can grab
that data the other idea I had is
passing it by props but either way it
might not be a bad idea to put the
search term in the URL because if we can
get that working it would enable users
to then save a search term or save a
search and then they can come back and
you know let's say they bookmarked a
search and the same results who will be
there and so there's there's definitely
some other benefits to doing it this way
it may not be the most direct way I
think profs would be a little bit more
direct but I think this is something
that we probably should do okay let me
let me go back then so unless someone
has a different idea for how to do this
I guess we'll move along and basically
start working in the search component to
do two things one check to see if
there's a search term in the URL and
then if there is initiate a search okay
so that's what we want to do here if we
run into a dead end there we could
potentially attempt to pass a search
term by props and maybe that would be a
little bit easier I'm not sure about it
though so I'm going to make a little bit
of space
so we can focus on this let me know if
the font is too small I could make it a
little bigger so right now a search is
is triggered on on a change in the
search input so I guess we could hmm
okay it looks like the fonts too small
so let me I'll make that bigger okay
I don't think I need go much bigger than
that without it being pretty hard to see
just wouldn't be able to see that much
code at once but so hopefully this is
okay so I'm thinking you know there's a
few ways we could do this we could put
the search term into the input in in
this page or we could manually trigger a
search so what I mean by that is let's
say like when the component loads we'll
just call fetch search term alright
after we've already set the state for
the search string okay so either way I
think we can get it to work
Michael says why not cache the search on
the client side I think that's a great
idea
and that's definitely a feature we could
work on today I'm just I'm worried about
doing this though
okay
all right so let's try first off let's
let's take the first step let's just see
if we can get the URL the search time
out of the URL so I suppose so you know
maybe want to do this on on a mount so
we'll try a component did mount and this
is a built in lifecycle method so that
means it comes by default with with
react with react and this will run when
the component Mouse so within here let's
try we'll just try to do a console Oh
actually you know what we could do
search term let's just have the habit
appear right in the the input so we'll
have a search term appear in the input I
just need to remember what part of the
state that goes into so we're yet
okay
value is search term okay so instead of
console.log we could say this state
search term equals and then just to
start out let's do like a window
location and then I can't remember what
it what it is I might have to look this
up
anybody remember off the top of their
head it's window location what to get
the the query string is it query yeah
let me let me look this up on my other
screen
that's a
all right so I'm just checking out
window dot location on mdn Mozilla
developer Network that's a really good
resource and I'm hoping that they show
all of the different options for window
dot location
it's
all righty returns an object let me just
check this here in our in our console
let's clear this out the location and
let's see what gets searched there we
are search window location search okay
so we'll get you see the the value of
search here make it a bit bigger where
we are gonna have to do some some stuff
to get this this value out of there
so let's not worry about this for now I
just want to see when we get something
so we can do search okay and let's see
if this works
oops I'm sorry I definitely should not
have done that I'm sure one of you
probably caught that and are already
telling me in the chat so this states
are sure
oops
this set States and now we're gonna do
search term and this is will
okay all right that's what we want to do
you know like I'm a little bit worried
about here is we are doing server-side
rendering so obviously window is not
going to work for server-side rendering
so we'll see how that that works out
let's see if this even works
I saw refresh okay I guess it didn't
work we can let's be 100% sure by going
to our react dev tools and let's see
what our state is search term yep search
term is still blank so for whatever
reason I suppose component did mount is
not working so she
all right michael says window location
search dot substring one actually let's
let's try that in the in the console to
see if that would that would work not
still giving us the same yeah it's just
taking out the question mark which I
guess I mean it's a little bit better
without the question mark
oh okay Nikki says I can't find that
response again but get initial props has
access to the query program so you can
check for one there for the first search
making URL URL shareable hmm sorry sorry
about the ons for some reason I just
yuan so much when I'm streaming okay
alright let's try that let's try to run
good initial props and see if we have
more luck with that okay and it looks
like we can access the query parameter I
think we ought to go to the
documentation first to see exactly how
we do this so I'm gonna go to next J s
on github and let me make this bigger
and I'm gonna try to find gets initial
props okay there we are
so fetching data and component lifecycle
actually this is good to know I didn't
realize you could use these for
stateless components cool props all
right here we are so good initial props
receives an object with these properties
pathway and query ok cool we should be
able to get the query in awesome
Nikki said types next in browser the
first result is next Jas github page
sounds about right
yep I'm there often okay alright let's
see I don't think they have example of
getting the query that would be kind of
cool but it shouldn't be too difficult
all right this actually another way to
do it could have made that a link all
right it's fine it works the way we do
it yeah we do
he's what I said
all right let's see what we get with
with query here I guess I can copy and
paste this oops this one and then we'll
just change it to what we need okay
let's get rid of this one actually let's
keep that for now and then we'll copy
and paste what we need in today so right
we want the query and let's see
you should do this or not
oops you know surprise should resolve an
object that found a defined set
what if I have to return it something
area
nothing's happening there okay why maybe
I can do this
drops query let's do a console log
mm-hmm that's weird for some reason
nothing we're doing a component dead
mountain is actually working
okay check my time okay about five
minutes I'll come back to the live chat
and and answer some questions okay all
right let me think
actually you know what we can we can see
what's what's here if we go to react
let's check out this and we should be
able to see it in props
okay so props query okay so we're
getting the older version so in the
documentation down here it says if
you're using with router you just get
these three in which our query then is
an object and it didn't give us the info
that we needed so
all right let me see why it's it's
annoying this instead of another one I
usually don't like to just read when I'm
streaming but I think this section is
definitely gonna help us here
Oh curtaincall says is there two
component did mom ever do I have it
twice that might explain why it's not
working
that's excellent
awesome okay so evidently our component
did mount we have two of them and that's
why it's not working actually though
I think
yeah actually let's let's do that let's
um yeah let's go back to what we were
doing and then we don't even have to
worry about why we're getting you know
one form of the information we should
get in get in a few props instead of the
other form that we want okay so what
we'll do then is get rid of that and put
it down here okay why am I getting this
Oh cuz it's the second good job catching
that that's uh I didn't even see that so
he did a curtain call thank you
alright ok so let's see now if it'll
actually change alright cool
ok so that that actually did work so it
changed this and now it has what we want
but well not exactly what we want right
so let me go up by some of you put in
who did it Albert
okay so Albert said we could split split
what we've got here okay
I think my timers yeah my timers going
to go off okay so next step in our next
Pomodoro session it's going to be let's
grab the actual term out of here and
leave all the rest off and then we'll
initiate a search which I actually this
shouldn't be too too hard the rest of it
is pretty I think it's pretty
straightforward okay let me set set this
time out of five minutes I'm going to
scroll all the way to the top of the
chat and just work my way down so if you
just ask something I may not get to it
in this five-minute session but I'll get
to it after the next moment or session
I'm just kind of skimming down and
trying to find the questions here Nicki
says how you doing how's the wrist I'm
doing way less coding lately need a
break just watching revelant relevant
video daily this is this is the one no
pressure yeah my wrist is a stone okay
it's just it still hurts so the timeline
I think is like it'll actually feel
worse than it did before the surgery for
about six weeks then it will start to
feel better but I'm looking at maybe
like three months before I should I'm
really feeling normal so I'm gonna try
to strengthen it just maybe like stretch
it a little bit because right now it's
pretty stiff so I'm just gonna try to do
more and more with it every day and see
how that goes
but I mean just typing all day like at
the end of the day my mother's too sore
just from that so like without putting
any weight on it at all it's just good
sore so it just it was just a time you
know I mean which is expectable you know
after after surgery it's expected
yeah it's expected after surgery
[Music]
Nietzsche says added trim teach to that
check and handle surge prevents spaces
from triggering search oh that's a good
idea that's a really good idea
Nikki says I posted something on an
issue a while ago about making the
search UI URL shareable going to look
for it yeah I remember I remember you
posted on that issue so yeah I remember
you posted that and I remember thinking
it's a good idea at the time but I
wasn't sure if that was something we'd
be able to get in before launch and
remind me after the next session to give
you an update on launch date I just had
a pretty long meeting this morning where
we talked a lot about what's gonna
happen on the website so I do have some
updates on that curtain closes font size
is okay but it's so very bright and
clumsy it is bright it is bright I'm not
sure what a clumsy font means but I
guess I'm open to suggestions for fonts
though Jeannot us should new junior
developers skip Ruby on Rails Python
Django and PHP laravel and just focus on
angular react to you node and Express in
MongoDB it just depends on what you want
to work on if if you have the ability to
just pick what you want to work on I
mean I would go more with the full stack
JavaScript you know type type of stuff
like I to me it's like if you can learn
one language and do front-end and
back-end like why not you know instead
of trying to learn two different
languages all right you're gonna have to
know JavaScript no matter what if you're
gonna do anything at all with front-end
so that that would be my my option but
you don't always have that luxury
sometimes you get a client or you get a
job and you have to learn you know what
you need to to get the job done so you
know I think you'll be fine either way
but I would lean more towards the full
stack JavaScript Powe pokken Buchan lung
sorry if I'm mispronouncing that but pou
Cleveland says actually what is this
project it is a the main website for the
university that I work for
Albert says isn't this project a little
too big for just one developer I don't
know maybe it is but I'm the only one
working on it well I shouldn't say that
you are helping a lot so yeah but it's
just me so at some point in the future
it'd be awesome if we can hire some more
developers here and I would have a team
but right now there's only two
developers in my department and we both
work on totally separate projects so
this is what I have right now okay my
timer is up I'm gonna jot down where I'm
leaving off here in the comments okay
all right so let's reset this timer here
for 25 minutes after the sessions up
I'll get to the rest of your questions
and where were we oh okay you know what
let's we're on the search now what do we
want to do I think was Nick he had an
idea to do the the trim actually I'm not
gonna worry about that right now because
then I'm gonna lose track I'll just try
to remember that if I forget it and you
have time Nicky please just make it an
issue or something or I mean if I if you
don't have time don't worry about it
I'll try to remember but I really want
to get this working in this next
Pomodoro session so I'm just going to go
straight to it even if it's not ideal
okay so we now have the data and we just
need to split this string
all right so let's see here we can do
[Music]
see actually let's just look up okay so
for those especially for those who are
known I don't want this I want the MTN
especially for those of you are new
sometimes it can seem like there's a lot
of stuff to learn you have to remember
it but like realistically I've been
doing this for at least five years I'm
being paid full-time to do this and I
can't remember exactly how to use the
split right so it's not a big deal to
have this stuff memorized when all you
have to do is type it into the search
bar and now you have it so and I kind of
like doing this because I usually learn
something new about a thing so even
though I'm just trying to figure out
what's the syntax if I spend a little
extra time reading this I find out you
know new stuff so anyway what I'm trying
to say is just don't get too bent out of
shape if you can't automatically
remember syntax for how to do things
because really it's it's not a big deal
okay so we got our separator and there
are limits so our separator in this case
is going to be that equal sign so we
need our string dot split and then the
equal sign and that'll give us an array
and we should need the second value in
the array which in this case would be
one because the race started zero okay
so let's go back and try this out whoops
it's in our component mount here we are
so instead of just this set state and
we're adding window.location search it's
going to be window location search dot
splits and then it's going to be one
oops Metta equals sorry equals and I
don't know if we can do this all at once
but I'm a little bit curious so I'm
gonna say looks should be parentheses
equals you know probably should put this
area okay equals and I'm gonna try to do
this I don't think I don't know if it'll
work but if it does that'll be kind of
cool when it'll let us keep this all in
one line so let's save that and we
should see the result now yeah it works
okay cool so if you're not sure what I
just did there
so from this this value is giving us
that whole search thing with the
question mark and equal sign and then
once we split it now it returns an array
right that has two items in the array
the zero with item in the first item
right so now we say we just want the
first item so what gets returned out of
here is a string that's that search term
that we're looking for okay so this is
actually going to work perfectly unless
for some reason we have more than one
parameter there in the query string in
which case we would have to modify this
I can't really foresee a reason why we
would have more than one on the search
page so I think this should be safe for
now but just just for you all if you're
trying to do something like this if you
think you may have more than one thing
you're you're definitely not going to be
able to do it like this just like this
you have to modify it a bit okay so now
that we have this and we've put it in
the state what we can do so we've set
the state and then we can trigger let me
be I want to double check this function
to make sure this will work we can
trigger fetch search term okay we don't
have to pass anything yeah
so let's do that and let's say this
fetch search term okay let's see if that
works
hmm
all right that's interesting okay so
let's see what this whoops I want to see
what the this ended up being how
interesting okay maybe that's pulling
from somewhere else let's double check
so we're setting the state to that value
what for to say we're setting search
term to equal that but maybe it's
pulling from somewhere else this fetch
search term so say base search string
this state search term okay it is
supposed to be grabbing the search term
and then also the search type is
supposed to be on the end of that
so we shouldn't have anything so by
default there's not going to be any
parameters at the end
this is weird to the search term
yeah this this should be okay in this
state search term
who
all right I'm gonna console.log within
here
let's see if that'll work it's giving me
a an error there but
let's see
all right
let me go back let's double check in our
react dev tools let's see what we have
there's a Search Search time is the okay
all right that's interesting
alright I'm gonna I want to see what
what gets triggered on this search here
on change this gets search results maybe
we should do that instead
yeah let's do get search results I think
I was skipping a few functions and
trying to go straight to that one so not
sure if this will solve the problem but
this is probably the way we want to go
anyway so let's do that you know what
I'm gonna move these up because I'm used
to these being up at the top I just feel
more comfortable if they are okay I like
having the default like life some
lifecycle methods there at the top okay
so instead of fetch search term it's
going to be get search results okay
cannot read properly other kind of
probably target of an assign start so
you
50 or 96
why am i using their okay
[Music]
okay so the search term is getting set
to value but there is no value are so
maybe then what we want to do is D
bounced search okay let's do that then
okay
hey there we are it worked this time
cool okay let's verify that again make
sure it works okay great now let's try
it let's try it again
straight from this this search
awesome so we've actually added to kind
of layers of functionality not only will
that work from that search input but
also now any URL you know we can type
whatever we want in and it'll
automatically do a search so this will
enable you know being able to bookmark
search results
which is awesome now the only thing we
need to change is right now if I were to
do a search straight from this page then
you see this stays the same right so we
need to update it so a search from the
search page actually updates this as
well and we can do that with the the
next router so that'll be the next step
for then and then also we're gonna have
to hook up this one instead of just a
side drawer but that shouldn't be too
hard it's just going to be a copy and
paste into this app bar component so see
how much time we have on which we can
get done okay a little over 10 minutes
let me check to the real-time each one
okay
actually you know what I'm going to
since we got this working and the rest
of it is just gonna be a matter of kind
of copying what we've already done I'm
gonna end now even though it's a little
bit early and go to the questions that
way I'll have a little bit more time for
questions I do have to make it over
somewhere else here on campus to do some
paperwork and the person I need to meet
I believe is leaving in about an hour so
I want to make sure I can get over there
in enough time so I should probably
double-check I'm gonna double-check the
email and do one before
oh actually no I think I have more time
than that yeah I do have more time all
right let's try to get something done
then sorry about that
so thing they're gonna hear for another
two hours so so we do have time so let's
all right well let's add this in over
here as well so so that this also will
work also it'd be cool to add make it so
that we could hit enter so that's
actually the only new functionality that
I think will be added with this so let's
let's do that then I'm not sure if I've
ever done that before with react I don't
think I have alright so this would be
cool I'll learn I wanted something new
here okay
also I'm not going to do it on here
it'll be over here in the drawer
component
alright so the handle search needs to be
triggered when we hit enter all right so
I'm just gonna look this up if anybody
knows how to do it put it in the chat
please otherwise let's look this up and
let's say detect okay awesome
so stack overflow to the rescue this is
exactly what we need we need to call an
event after pressing whoops Enter key
I don't know what I just did okay
according to react ducks there alright
let's just read the react dog since that
keyboard events
alright awesome so there's an on key
press and then we can do the character
code nice
all right so on yeah on key press so
let's add that into oh yeah it's we'll
put it here on our input on key press
and let's see let's see if there's an
example here
keepers okay interesting
okay so we're gonna add okay all right
this works this handle search change
see
curtain closed saying keypress which 13
action is there a way I could do it
right there
alright I'm not sure Michael Satan in a
switch yeah no but I know the answer
value is 13 but I was just wondering if
there was some like shorthand way that I
could do that like here right or if I
actually had to modify this handle
search oops
it shouldn't have been handle search
change it should it
now it should be handle search area okay
all right Nikki saying doesn't an input
inside a former automatically submit on
enter or does react prevent that yeah I
don't well I don't know if we will even
want a submit in this case you know well
ok Justin has some some code here
alright this looks really cool let me do
that
okay let me see if this works and then
if it does I'll go in and explain what's
happening
unexpected character that's weird okay
so that did not work okay here's another
one
all right so that didn't work so I'm not
going to go over it since it didn't work
but it would have been cool it looked
cool all right I guess we could just
just do it like like we saw on the
example on Stack Overflow right it would
be cool to do it differently but this
will definitely work okay
this is weird why is it still giving me
there
I said this is really weird I think let
me try this again
I think something may have gotten copied
but some money get a copy weird let me
try this one more time
why she was so
okay Andrews not doing anything
okay so that's I mean we're not getting
air or anything but nothing's happening
when I hit enter
okay
I wonder if we're getting the right
let's try T code and we'll go with let's
try I never tried to just use the name
of the key before so I mean maybe it
works it but let's just try it like this
and see if that is the issue
nope not the issue
oh well Justin I think that was an
awesome awesome idea I'm not a hundred
percent sure why it's not working
curtain closes try e key which try enter
lowercase instead of its or uppercase
since what Albert says key console.log
okay we could console.log it yeah that
makes sense
so let's do that for now let's just get
rid of that and do
EQ okay so what this should do is just
tell us what key is being pressed in the
console all right that should work right
answers should definitely be working
there okay so let's go so this should
definitely work if ii and so now we're
we're doing a ternary right so shouldn't
you do on key press e without braces
curtain calls shouldn't you do on keep
receipt without the braces no we need
the braces in react because otherwise it
won't interpret that as JavaScript okay
so if a equals enter if it does equal
enter then let's call this handle search
otherwise we're going to say no okay
food okay so what is happening let's
alright let's just try to figure out
where the problem is happening okay so
we're just gonna console.log the word
search
it should console.log when the enter key
is pressed right oops
okay awesome so okay cool
all right so we just had the we know
that this is working so the issue let's
check this out
handle search if this state search it's
not equal a lot of professing okay so we
need to do oh you know what I wonder if
it's at this issue so that's that's
gonna be my guess it's it's at this
issue within here
so that Nikki just said the same thing
it's at this issue isn't it yeah I think
so so let's see how we can
let me see what okay so Justin sing try
it like that
okay I'm gonna try that first because
that's gonna be the easiest thing if
this works then this would be very easy
all right
awesome that was it that was it so with
so normally in in react you can you can
just do this right you can say this dot
handle search right and you don't need
and in fact you don't want to actually
you know put the parentheses here to
keep normally do to invoke a function
right but in this case since it's not
exactly the same right we're actually
entering into the inside of another
function right we needed to invoke that
so awesome
great job Justin just for coming up with
this in the first place and then also
for figuring out what the problem was so
really appreciate that and that took a
little bit longer but this is honestly
this looks really clean I like it
and we didn't have to modify handle
search and clutter it up there with with
some if statements so actually I really
like this right so we avoid even having
to call that function right so we do our
check here otherwise we would have been
actually calling this other function and
then doing the check so I I don't know
the difference in performance is
probably so so small its insignificant
but I like how it looks and it was kind
of cool cool to learn you know how to do
that so anyway that's all I'm gonna do
for today because our my timer ran out a
while ago I was just so into it I wanted
to keep going until we got it so we
pretty much got almost everything that I
wanted what we definitely achieved what
I wanted to achieve
we added some extra things I'd like to
do there and we didn't get to all of
those but pretty cool
so I think it's definitely a good a good
stream in terms of getting things
accomplished that is and we're gonna
come I'm gonna commit this so you all
can have the code available to you on
github immediately so let's add this new
feature and let's say enable side drawer
search info beside your search yeah that
works this does affect an open issue so
let's put yes and let me see let's
figure out what issue I love it when I
type G in and get up actually is higher
than Gmail in my suggested size that's
pretty awesome so I'm gonna go check out
the issues here I know I have an issue
about this
I guess would just be under implement
search maybe I don't have a separate
issue okay I don't think I made a
separate issue about it I do have a
separate credit card in my Trello board
for it but it's the same issue that's
issue number 74 so we're just gonna say
re4 regarding number 74 okay and when we
add that in then there's gonna be a
little spot and I guess I could show you
how this looks right now because I think
I've done it before so you can see here
the reference oh yeah did I say
regarding I mean reference I don't know
why I thought it was regarding okay
anyway so this issue is now referenced
in this commit it's referenced in this
commit in this commit in this commit so
at least kind of a nice log of you know
hey this is getting worked on and here's
what we've done to work on it okay so
you don't want to have to manually come
here and give an update but this lets
everybody know that you know this issue
isn't dead right it's it's being
actively worked on and here's what's
been done alright so that went through
it passed all the tests and now I can do
a git push and this will go straight up
to github and y'all can check it out
feel free to fork this repo and make any
contributions that you want submit a
pull request I'm definitely open to that
and I'll help you out if you have any
trouble with it alright cool so let's
check this we won't get an auto refresh
on on github at least I don't think you
will but here we are there's there's our
commit so enable side drawer search
alright cool so I'm gonna scroll back up
to where I left off in the chat so if
you have any questions or anything or
comments put it in there any when it
comes to the comments I totally enjoy
compliments and nice things but if you
have something critical to say feel free
to say it I want to make these streams
as good as they possibly can
be so that they're helpful to you all so
if you think that there's something I'm
doing wrong or something that I could do
that I'm not going please you know let
me know I can't always do everything you
know that you say but I definitely want
to hear what what you think so don't be
afraid to put critical comments in there
some occasionally people put you know
comments they're pretty pretty rude and
I'm totally cool with that it doesn't
bother me
especially because 99.9% of you are
super positive and nice about it that
definitely outweighs everything else and
if I ever get to the point where 99% of
them are all negative then I'll know
that maybe it's time to stop because
this is not useful for you oh okay
save fall dean says hi hey how's it
going welcome to the stream Alexandro
says a little afternoon I'm Brazilian
hey how's it going thanks for watching
Anand wants to know where the first
video in the series is or the playlist
there's a playlist on so if you click on
playlists on free code camp go to the
project number 5 playlist for live
coding with Jessie I think it might be
called react project 5 or something but
if you go to that playlist that should
have all the videos in order there's
quite a few videos this is number 91
just in this playlist and with project 5
so you know I definitely recommend if
you're gonna watch maybe try to watch it
on too time speed and you know maybe
skip around videos just to focus on what
you're interested in if you have the
time to watch them all that's that's
awesome but if you don't have the time
then that's probably the best way to go
about it ok and it says hey hey Anna
how's it going I feel like I haven't
talked to you in a really long time I
guess it has been because I didn't
for a while after my surgery and stuff
so yeah let me know how's how's it going
what's new with you I'm really glad you
get to catch the stream today
huh curtain call one point said it's bad
to code when you get got so very tired
yeah that is it's for sure so this is
just a little tip from curtain call and
from me in case you haven't been there
yet sometimes it seems like a good idea
to stay up really late in code but I've
found that I definitely make more
mistakes after a certain point like I
stay up late I could I I do good for a
while but after a certain point it's
just not worth it
right because you mess things up so be a
good idea to like find out where that
point is for you and then stop whenever
I it when I first moved into the house
that I live in right now it needed a lot
of work
it was the the house was like completely
trashed so we got a good deal on it but
we had to work so I used to have a rule
that if if I messed up twice in a row I
had I'm done for the night so that means
like if I measured wrong twice if I cut
if I had to cut something twice in row
because you know I was like building
walls and stuffs was cutting to life ORS
and drywall and stuff like that so I
would say okay if I had to recut
something twice I'm done because at that
point I would just be wasting materials
and wasting my time so I kind of have a
similar thing with my code right if I
start really messing up like
consistently then I'm done because at
that point there's not it's just not
efficient anymore like I would get more
benefit if I slept for a little bit and
then woke up and started a code again so
I mean sometimes it's an emergency like
servers down or something you really got
to do it but if you can that's a good
point to go to sleep so anyway hopefully
that rule will help somebody at some
point lock Sean says which j/s framework
is best for mobile app development I I
would recommend react so react native
okay I think react native is good I've
messed with like doing ionic before it's
pretty good but but honestly I've been
super impressed with react native with
easy it is to get things going with the
quality of the apps I I really I like
react native so that's my my
recommendation I've heard you view
either already has something to do
native apps with you or they're gonna
come out with it so I don't know what
how far along they are with that or if
it's possible yet but I mean that's
another option but obviously I've never
used it so I can't really comment on you
know the pros and cons of it o Aniki
said also flutter Nikki's heard the
flutter is pretty awesome has anybody
used flutter so if you're not sure with
flutter is it's um it's like a framework
or some type of system to build native
apps so I didn't do they I don't know if
they just announced it at the Google i/o
conference or it was already out and
they just talked about it but that was
the first time I heard about it but I
haven't used it yet I haven't really I
haven't watched any videos on it or
anything like that but I would like to
know how it is so if anybody has used
flutter to build an app or anything like
that let me know in the chat please or
in the comments down below if you're
watching the recording of this because
I'm I'm definitely interested in it I
mean I'm still like I like react native
but I'm always open to learning you know
new things luck Sean says I think I have
to learn a lot to learn react framework
well I mean you don't have to know that
much to just get started with it but to
really do more advanced thing it thinks
it does take a little while for bigger
apps like state management becomes a big
issue so there are some things about
react that take a lot of time to learn
but you know just to get up and start
with something basic you know it
shouldn't take too much work it does
depend on how familiar you are you are
already with JavaScript though but you
know don't don't be intimidated by it I
was really into him
by it at first but it ended up being a
lot easier than I thought it would be
especially react native react native was
so much easier than I thought for some
reason I was just super intimidated by
it but it ended up being not only easier
than I thought but way more fun than I
imagined in a in a sadhu I feel not bad
actually my wrist hurts but the doctor
said that's normal it should hurt
he actually said I was able to give him
like a normal handshake with my right
hand which is the one that I surgery on
and he was pretty impressed that I was
able to shake his hand like it like I
did so I guess that means I'm doing well
so I just need to relax and take it take
it slow other than that I feel pretty
good I haven't really been able to do
like my normal exercise routine so
that's got me thrown off a bit and from
all that time off that I had had like
not working out my sleep schedule is so
thrown off so like so hard for me to go
to sleep which is probably why I'm
yawning because I'm running off of less
sleep than I normally get because I just
have trouble falling asleep but anyway
and it thanks for asking I'm not going
to go on anymore because I don't know
how many people actually care about my
sleeping habits right now but I
appreciate you asking that
Aniki says do you have a thick elastic
band those are great for wrist exercises
oh I'm sure I have one somewhere I have
to see I think right now I don't want to
actually add any weight or resistance
because my wrists like hurts enough just
with without anything like I don't see
like me just doing this right now hurts
like and if I try to actually like spin
it in a circle like that that hurts so I
don't really don't need to add any
weight
and it says my brain is waiting for
Maury ah awesome awesome I'm gonna check
that out after after the stream is over
so hopefully I'll have time to get it
merged in today I'm super excited about
that thank you so much for for
contributing curtaincall says question
do you manually normalize search input
query somehow or it's reactor outers
duty I imagine things are happening on
react so I'm not doing anything to
normalize it so I'm kind of trusting
that the router and so I'm not using
react router I'm using the next router
so although I love react router since
next Jas has a router built-in when I
use next I do that if I use create react
app I use react router if I use your act
native I use react router
actually it's called react native router
but same same but just for for react
native Michael's says the first day of
school for for the kid freshman high
school I love him but he's been getting
on my last nerve now the teachers can
have him back yeah my my kids are gonna
go to school soon too I have mixed
feelings about it so like I'm not home
with them all day so I don't know like
I'm gonna miss them but at the same time
like usually I'm at work during that
time so it's not gonna be that different
from me the only difference is like I'm
gonna have to be more strict about
getting getting them to bed on time and
I'll probably have to wake up earlier so
I can get him ready help get him ready
for school and driving to school so yeah
I actually might my youngest son Ambrose
is he just turned 4 and he's gonna get a
4 year old preschool so he hasn't been
to school before and he was really
excited but then he told me a few days
ago that he was nervous about it so I
hope he does alright I'm worried about
him I don't want him to be sad for for
preschool so we'll see how that goes
Oshin at some point said late again what
did I miss
I'm not sure how far along we are when
you came in so I guess I'm not sure you
could definitely check out the recording
though but I can't remember at what
point we were when when you asked that
curtaincall asks it looks like you're
using headless wordpress as a JSON
back-end any optimizations done or it's
good out of the box so yeah for the
search we're just using the REST API I
added a plug-in to get multiple post
types so normally with the REST API you
can only get one post type at a time
since we're trying to search for
everything at once we are using that
plug-in otherwise there's no
optimizations now for some of the other
sections on the website I'm using graph
QL so we have a graph QL plug-in that
lets you use graph QL with WordPress so
but in terms of just what we worked on
today it's just REST API with one
additional plug-in and I don't know how
familiar you are with WordPress but the
REST API used to be an additional
plug-in and it was kind of like in a
testing phase it's now merged into
WordPress core so that means it comes by
default with WordPress and it's turned
on by default and it's stable so it's
safe to use in production
okay
I'm skipping over some of the questions
because they here because they had to do
with debugging what was happening there
so they're not really relevant anymore
Nietzsche says oh cool a loading
indicator when did that get added Monday
alright Michael already answered that
yeah we did that on Monday okay Nikki
mentioned the trim again our I'm glad
you mentioned that again because I would
be likely to forget
gia says hi just tuned in please tell me
you're gonna take a look on login with
the routing so admin slash user I'm not
exactly sure what you're asking that so
Gio if you could explain that a little
bit more what you mean by that I'd
definitely be happy to answer it but I'm
not sure right now how do you answer
that
Phoenix says say I had a one on one call
with Quincy today such an amazing guy he
is it was great talking to him oh that's
awesome
yeah Quincy is really cool so I've
talked to him a few times like mostly
through email and things and also buy a
video call and yeah really nice and
really good guy so I'm actually gonna
get a chance to meet him and a lot of
the other free code camp people in
person next week so like next weekend I
will be in in New York for like a free
code can't meet up psycho thing so I'm
really excited for that so I know I
mentioned this I think on Monday but
I'll mention it again because I'm sure
there's different people watching with
just a different time slot that I I
streamed in next week I will be in Salt
Lake City Utah for a while and then I'll
also be in New York City I'll be staying
in in Brooklyn so if anybody is is
anywhere near Salt Lake City Utah
or New York City and would like to hang
out please let me know that would be
kind of cool so I just I'm gonna send me
a DM on some social media or whatever
and be happy to like I don't know go get
a coffee or whatever you know so let's
see I lost my place sorry
see
all right cool Kingsley says great job
kurtosis drumroll nope
let's see tech tricks a good job thank
you those all came right at the time
when we finally got it to work so thank
you I appreciate that
I mean it's it was kind of like a matter
of time before we narrow down what the
problem was and really it was Justin who
came up with the final final solution
there curtaincall says what's the name
of the plugin for committing from
console the one referencing repository
fixes and so on
it's called committees in okay Michael
already answered that yeah so check out
committed son it's really cool
Harshit who frequently watches this the
stream and it's done a lot of
contributing Harshit found that and set
that up for this project so one ain't
want to give credit where that's do it
wasn't I didn't feel find out about it
he did but I'm glad he did
mammy says sorry for mispronouncing that
let me know how I should pronounce it
but mammy says thanks this really helped
me a lot you're a great teacher I just
can't see it but I listen okay yeah I'm
really sorry about the the font if it
was hard to see I really I can't really
go any bigger cuz we wouldn't be able to
see enough code on the screen for it to
make sense but I'm really glad that it
that it helped you out though
[Applause]
Evie for I don't know how to pronounce
that but says what's the name of your
knight github themed extension github
dark and he's just called github dark
humberto says I tend to think more
clearly when I'm exhausted yeah I mean
sometimes it there is some things about
being a little bit tired that can help
you but at some point tired is just not
good for work at least that's been my
experience
Pupuke in lung says it's so interesting
this live hope to see more often Oh
awesome I'm glad you liked it yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna try to do this as many
times a week as I as I can and I'm gonna
get a new computer for my home office
soon that should make it so that I can
stream better with better quality from
home so hopefully that'll that'll mean I
get to stream more often
oh cool so Niki added a PR that had
shrimp awesome thank you too he he says
pretty sure that's the smallest PR ever
it might be
Michael says I think I did once that
fixed a one-word typo and a readme
that's okay it does it still counts as a
full request
Tigran says the word headless triggers
me I mean person completely wrecked my
life with the Raspberry Pi headless
server let's see Munir says hi hey how's
it going thanks for watching
Adrian says hi how are you pretty good
pretty good how you doing Nicky says
haven't written any code for a while and
don't plan to either but that that hit
felt good good
curtain cole says just returned to
wordpress after many years and it's
getting better now includes json rest
api it looks okay yeah and actually
there's going to be a new let wordpress
editing experience is called gutenberg I
believe is built with react and it uses
the REST API so I haven't tried it yet
but it's gonna go live with the next
release of WordPress so you can you can
choose to go back to the old experience
if you download a plugin for it but
across the board for all new
installations it's going to be live so
be ready for that if you have WordPress
or if you're if you're away from
WordPress I just want to check out check
it out then I don't know exactly when
the new release is coming but that's
whenever it does come it's Gutenberg
will be will be there
curtaincall says I enjoy the teamwork
yeah awesome all right Michael so
speaking of which where's where's harsh
had been needs his he's on vacation yeah
he's on vacation right now he stopped in
just like really briefly on Monday and
said hi instead he was on vacation
he-he-ha-ha says will you make a discord
server do we have a discord server yet
or not I don't think we do we had a lot
of other things but not a discord server
actually let me know if you all think it
would be cool to have a discord server
for for this stream let me know I could
maybe think about starting one I know we
already have several other places things
that you've started up and like none of
them has ever I think really taken off
and you they usually die out but I don't
know I have several other discord
servers that I'm checking regularly so
for me it might not be a bad thing since
I already am on discord frequently so
anyway just let me know
Baraka says which date and time is the
meet up in New York
whatever let me see I don't remember
what the date is it's like the 19th I
don't bring my calendar up on my other
screen so I can tell you what the date
is okay so I'm flying into New York on
the 18th and then the meetup is that
night so the the meetup is like
invite-only but I will be there on the
18th and the 19th and then I will fly
back on the 20th so I will be around not
that long but I'll be around for a
little bit and then I'll be in Salt Lake
City I'll get there on the 15th and I
will leave like around midnight on the
on the 17th
hehas what languages do you know I'm
assuming this programming languages so
JavaScript some PHP I've done some stuff
but I wouldn't say that I know Python
Java C++ C I think that's it Oh solidity
yeah so those are those are the
programming language that I've I've done
things with of course I'm not counting
HTML or CSS as programming languages and
I'm not interested in arguing whether
they are or not but I mean I think it
kind of goes without saying if your
front-end dev you you know HTML CSS
Justice says I'm giving a Lunch and
Learn at work on progressive web apps in
two weeks do you have any advice for me
I don't know honestly I think it would
be cool if you're gonna give a talk on
progressive web apps I think it might be
really cool to have a demo app available
just so that people can can download it
on their phone and then have them put
their phone on airplane mode and then
use it that's kind of cool just to
demonstrate that you can use stuff
offline because that that like generally
is like that's the most impressive thing
about progressive web apps for most
people so I think that would be kind of
a fun like hands on thing and it could
be something like right at the beginning
you put the URL up there and then they
can just choose to go to it or not and
you know let them know throw an airplane
mode and so I don't know that would be
kind of cool so they wouldn't just be
sitting there listening they'd also see
it you know firsthand so I don't know
that would be my my advice for that
hehas can you combine xml and java with
intelligent sure to pronounce that to
make an app i have i have no idea if
anybody else has any experience with
that please let us know but i have no
idea if you could
okay
Justices I would not have thought of
that good idea thank you oh yeah no
problem
if you if you can it'd be awesome if you
could let me know how it goes so after
you give the talk if you you know come
back to one of the the live streams and
the chat I'd love to hear how it goes
and if you end up like publishing any
slides or anything or a video of your
your presentation I'd love to see it
he says you should make live stream
tutorials teaching us the code I don't
know off to think about that I actually
I'm I keep seeing emails popping up
while I've been streaming and I'm on
currently on an email chain with some
people at the University discussing the
possibility of me actually becoming a
professor and teaching some web
development courses so I might be like
legit teaching so we'll see how that
goes if that actually happens I could
definitely see it being really
beneficial to do a lot of video
tutorials for you all and for my
students so that way yeah it'd be
difficult if I just go into classroom
demo demonstrate something and leave it
at that right it's it's so much better
if they would have the ability to rewash
things right so I'll probably end up
doing that so I don't know when that
will happen but based on like the tiny
preview messages that I've been seeing
going back and forth it seems like it's
a possibility
oh cool I had a few congratulations for
that thank you
it hasn't happened yet but it would be
cool if it does happen I would be an
adjunct professor which I don't know how
I jump professors work in other
countries but in the United States
they're usually not paid very much so it
wouldn't be like I'd make a bunch of
money off it but it would kind of be
like a fun thing to do and I think it
would be helpful it'd be helpful for me
because I would really have to kind of
learn even more to be able to teach it
and I think it would be really helpful
for the students as well to get some
like practical you know kind of
cutting-edge experience with what the
latest in web development is okay
anytime it is all right well this dream
is going on almost two hours now and
I've gotten through everything in the
live chat if I skipped over your
question it was definitely not
intentional so you know you can ask me
in the comments or DME or something and
I'd be happy to ask or you'll wait for
the next stream
let's see I'll be back in the office
tomorrow so I should be able to stream
and thank you all so much for all your
help today
I definitely couldn't have gotten this
far without you all I was you know super
helpful and yeah so think that's it for
me today so I'll see you see y'all
tomorrow hopefully and until then have a
great day